the left accelerates its cultural
authoritarianism with book bannings
big tech targetings and institutional
weaponization while the biden
administration continues to push forward
massive expansion of government i'm
benchmare this is the ben shapiro show
this show is sponsored by expressvpn
don't like big tech and the government
spying on you
visit expressvpn.com ben speaking of
which you may have noticed
that your privacy seems to be under
assault these days
you may be using incognito but you are
not in fact incognito you need a vpn to
protect you from
frankly your own internet service
provider very often but certainly from
hackers and other people who want your
data
i've been talking about expressvpn on
this show four months why haven't you
just done it go get a vpn
right now i'll tell you this there's
never been a more important time to
protect your digital rights that's why i
and thousands of my patriotic listeners
choose to secure our online data by
using expressvpn
you believe a vpn isn't for you because
you can just use the internet fine
without one
wrong that you are it's like leaving
your car unlocked at night sure most of
the time it'll be fine
and then one day somebody just drives
off with your car don't be that person
are you confused about how it works
expressvpn is an app for computers and
smartphones that encrypts your network
data
and reroutes it through a secure server
that means you can use the internet more
anonymously without having your activity
tracked
do you think vpns are complex only for
tech experts wrong with one button you
can download with another button
you basically activate it you're done
now you're protected take back your
privacy at expressvpn.com get three
extra months free
on a one-year package again that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com to get three extra
months for free
visit expressvpn.com ben right now
all righty so we are living
through an extremely tenuous time
it is very obvious that the country is
coming apart at the seams it was
happening before trump
it did not decelerate during trump and
despite the best attempts of the media
to claim that joe biden is a unifying
figure and that the country was going to
come back together
in fact the administration has not been
a unifying force
there is a there are centrifugal forces
right now that are tearing apart the
country
in very serious ways and it seems like
that is not going to decelerate anytime
soon
and it's weird because when you look at
joe biden sometimes he says the right
things frankly like yesterday for
example he came out and he said
communism is a terrible system it's
failed everywhere it's tried i i don't
think there's much of a difference from
socialism
and and you said yourself okay well this
is the kind of reasonable joe biden that
we were led to believe was going to be
president of the united states
in in 2020 and then within 24 hours joe
biden will also be saying
that if you are in favor of voter id
it's because you're a jim crow style
racist
well that sort of rhetoric is in fact
what is going to tear the country apart
because
there has been a movement brewing in
america for a decade at the very least
in which people particularly the left
declare people of the right to be nazis
and then they suggest it's okay to punch
a nazi and on a broad institutional and
governmental level
this has been the argument people i
don't like are white supremacists people
i don't like are nazis people i don't
like are the worst of the worst of the
worst
and therefore we are absolutely
justified in using every means at our
disposal
to shut this thing down to prevent
people from disseminating information
to to stop people from using individual
rights because individual rights of
course
can be a danger in germany post-world
war ii
there is a particular tactic used by the
government in order to quash
the the rise of nazism in the post-world
war ii era it was called strike bear
democracy
and the basic idea was that you could
not provide freedom of speech to say
hitlerian groups because if you did
then they would then use that freedom of
speech against the very freedoms of
germans and they would take over the
state again and pose a threat to the
world and so you had to quash them
you had to strangle it in the crib so to
speak
now never mind that that really had not
worked very well during the weimar
republic
hitler was jailed after the after the
beer hal pooch and then hitler emerged
from jail and he was more popular than
he'd been before he was put in jail
and and turns out that very often when
you try to prevent bad rhetoric
from gaining adherence banning the
rhetoric is a good way to
to make the rhetoric more appealing to
more people because then they feel that
they are
victims of some sort of transnational
conspiracy
but beyond that even if you believed
that striper democracy has been a
success
that banning for example the sale of
mineconf in germany has been a
net positive for germany you just be
very careful how you use those
principles because of course
the question is really not whether mind
comp ought to be banned in germany it's
who decides whether minecomp ought to be
banned in germany and when you take that
to an american context the question is
who decides what ought to be banned now
the founders took a pretty robust view
of political freedom in the united
states it wasn't unending there were
certain things that you could do like
try to overthrow the governments of the
united states or you could speak
in ways that were considered treasonous
and these things would not necessarily
be covered by the first amendment
there's a lot of
case law on this there's a lot of
writing by the founders on this sort of
stuff
but the freedom of speech and the
ability to descend
has historically been extremely broad in
the united states and for good reason
because the truth is that if you're a
progressive leftist if you're somebody
who's a progressive leftist
your best protection as a progressive
leftist historically speaking
has been the first amendment if the
conservative powers that be
had actually been able to prevent you
from speaking freely over the course of
the 20th century
then many of the left champion causes
never would have come to fruition
ranging from same-sex marriage to
radical centralization of governmental
power
so striper democracy is a power that has
to be used sparingly if at all and in
the united states there really is very
little precedence
for striped democracy when it has been
used in the past it's been used to
pretty nefarious effects ranging from
the alien sedition act
of the john adams administration to
woodrow wilson using the sedition acts
in order to crack down
on people who dissented from world war
one what we are seeing
right now is a sort of institutional
striper democracy where the government
knows its own limits in the sense that
the supreme court is not going to allow
overt
prevention by the government of speech
instead
the government has realized that it can
utilize the tools of institutional power
that exists outside of the government
in order to cram down its own agenda
it's essentially
state sponsored state initiated and
state advocated stripe democracy right
crack down on particular
points of view but the problem is that
the people who are making these
decisions
have a very broad view of what it is
that ought to be suppressed and so it
becomes extremely dangerous
when you see people who are in very high
positions of power talking about their
fellow
americans as though they are full-scale
motties talking about their fellow
americans
as though they are on the verge of a
birjal police
as though they are hitler and this
struck me forcibly yesterday when i was
reading this story from the washington
post about general mark
mark milley so uh i'll be honest with
you i really didn't know much about mark
milley until the past couple of months
and it seems to me that mark miller is a
fool i i don't know what else to take
away from his comments in front of
congress
that he's assigning how to be an
anti-racist by irmax kennedy
to american troops because americans
need american troops need to know why
the systems of the united states are
inherently and unfixably racist
and discrimination today is a remedy for
discrimination yesterday
his statements about that were full on
asinine and now there's an article that
has come out
uh based on the carol lennox and philip
rucker book i alone can fix it donald j
trump's catastrophic final year
talking about mark milley's view of
january 6th and everything that led up
to january 6th and post january 6th
and mark milley's perspective on this is
so unbelievably historically ignorant
and yes dangerous because when you
characterize your political opposition
in the worst possible way without any
true historical reference point you are
paving the way for exactly the sort of
measures that normally have to be used
for the world's worst people
right if the logic is the nazis had to
be fought on the beaches
and then you say oh yes and my next door
neighbor is also a nazi the implication
is
that your next door neighbor needs to be
treated like a nazi should be treated
so here's what mark milley had to say
and this is so historically ignorant i
mean it honestly looks as though
he once read a doomsbury cartoon
about world war ii and this is his only
historical reference for what happened
during world war ii
and in the lead up to the to the
hitlerian takeover of germany and
and the enabling act of 1933. according
to the washington post
millie described a stomach churning
feeling as he listened to president
trump's untrue com
complaints of election fraud drawing a
comparison to the 1933 attack on
germany's parliament building that
hitler used as a pretext to establish a
nazi dictatorship
this is a rashtag moment millie told
aids according to the book
the gospel of the fuhrer okay now
the united states is not to buy my
republic circa 1932 1933
it is not okay there are a wide variety
of dissimilarities ranging from the fact
that germany had suffered a catastrophic
loss in world war one
and then suffered an even more
catastrophic peace under the versailles
treaty
to the economic failures of the 1920s to
the failures of parliamentary government
that ended
essentially with the establishment of a
proto-dictatorship
under figures other than hitler in the
early 1930s
there there are wide variety of factors
that distinguish by my republic germany
from america circa 2021 like many many
many factors
okay and the comparison of donald trump
to hitler is of course
particularly ridiculous and it's also
particularly ridiculous that millie was
suggesting
that the january 6th attack on the
capital was in some sense a rashtag
moment
okay because if you know anything about
the rat stag fire what what you know
about the rest side power is the
fire is that a deranged communist that
set fire to the red stag building and
then hitler used that as a pretext
to round up communists and to have
the the german parliament pushed through
an enabling act that essentially
put all power of the state in his hand
right so the idea was that there was a
fire that was blown out of proportion
by the ruling powers that be hitler was
already chancellor at the time
and then that was used as the pretext to
centralize even more power
and basically get rid of the rashtag
entirely like
get rid of the entire german legislative
body
as an effectual part of government okay
well
what would the logic of that be with
regard to january 6 that a bunch of
trump supporters
storm morons and drugs stormed the the
capitol building
so that donald trump could according to
general milley
invoke the insurrection act against the
people
who were on his side purportedly
it doesn't make any sense internally
there's no logic to it there's no
consistency to it
at all okay so none of this makes any
sense
but the washington post piece is
basically all about how millie thinks
that that
not only was trump hilarion but that a
huge number of his supporters
were basically brown shirts and he used
this kind of language on on a regular
basis apparently which is scary
considering that he
is the head of the joint chiefs of staff
right so if you look further on in the
article
he said that millie said he was
determined to avoid a repeat of the
siege on the capitol a week after
january 6. he said everyone in this room
whether you're a cop whether you're a
soldier we're going to stop these guys
to make sure we have a peaceful transfer
of power
we're going to put a ring of steel
around the city and the nazis
aren't getting in the nazis aren't
getting
really the nazis like i'm i'm just
wondering
like does he it was like a couple of
hundred idiots
congress went about its business within
two hours of the halls of congress being
cleared
he suggested that he he feared an
american equivalent of brown shirts in
the street
after trump was speaking about the
election between november 4th and
january 6th
brown shirts in the streets now the
brown shirts were a paramilitary force
approved of
by the ruling administration and
encouraged to go perform acts like
kristallnacht in 1938 right so like
like there's no historical precedent for
what he's talking about but again it is
the it is the language that is being
used
about an entire side of the political
aisle because it's not even restricted
to
trump's language is wrong he is not
telling the truth about the election
that is terrible for our democracy it's
not restricted to that it's not
restricted to
the people who invaded the capitol
building on january 6th
are not only idiots and and drugs
but perform criminal acts and should go
to jail it's not bad it's
anybody who went to a trump rally
anybody who voted for trump right the
extension
outward toward because here's the thing
if trump is hitler
and hitlerian figure anyone who voted
for trump by extension voted for hitler
and those people are then complicit
in hilarion crimes and you can see this
taken to its sort of
full fruition when when you come when it
comes to the comments that a guy named
miles taylor made yesterday now you
never heard of miles taylor
until the last five seconds miles taylor
was the guy who wrote this anonymous
column in the new york times
talking about how there were people
inside the administration resisting
trump and there's a lot of
who could anonymous be was anonymous
actually mike pence
was anonymous actually maybe melania was
anonymous baron
there was all this idiot talk about who
who was anonymous
who could anonymous be a high rank it
turns out that anonymous was basically
anonymous he was this low-level official
in the trump administration who then
came out at first he lied
on cnn about it he said i'm not
anonymous and then it turns out he
wasn't on this and you wrote this column
about how trump was terrible and he
needed to be stopped from within okay
well yesterday miles taylor appeared on
msnbc's jason
with msnbc's jason johnson where he
proceeded to explain
that the biggest threat to the republic
is not isis it's not al qaeda it's not
chinese authoritarianism and communism
it's not russian aggression it's
conservatives and republicans
those are the greatest threats to the
republic now you can see the move here
the move here is going to be
your next door neighbor is the problem
and as we'll see this is going to
justify
the kind of crackdowns that democrats
have planned if that happens
you can see why the country is on the
verge of a split once your next door
neighbor is no longer just a person who
disagrees with you politically
but your actual enemy like a hilarion
enemy
what exactly are you supposed to do
other than taking the measures that
would have been necessary to stop hitler
in his tracks here was miles taylor
saying one of the more despicable things
i've heard in modern american politics
i'm a national security guy i've worked
in national security against isis and al
qaeda
and russia and the number one national
security threat i've ever seen in my
life
to this country's democracy is the party
that i'm in the republican party it is
the number one national security threat
to the united states of america
and i'll tell you this if my party
retakes the us house of representatives
in the next cycle
it's going to become a haunted house and
and the ghoul and the specter haunting
that house is going to be donald trump
they're the biggest national security
threats to the united states he's ever
seen in his life
now miles taylor seems like a fairly
young guy but
i'm 37 and the soviet union was still
around for the first few years of my
life
china right now is making aggressive
aggressive moves
not only throughout hong kong but with
regard to taiwan on the tech front
they're making aggressive moves
but according to miles taylor
republicans your next door neighbors or
maybe you
you are the true threats of the country
writ large you are the true threat
now what does this justify if you say
that everyone around you is a nazi this
means it's time for some striped
democracy applied to you and that's
precisely what the biden administration
apparently
is now going to push forward they're not
going to do it formally through the
actual auspices of government instead
they're going to hijack
encourage work hand in glove with
private institutions in order
to make sure that those private
institutions do their dirty work it
makes it very difficult for those
institutions to claim they are not state
actors
when as we'll see the white house is
openly acknowledging that it is
directing non-state actors to do things
the state actor itself could not do
we'll get to that in just one second
first let's talk about your sleep
quality so
as you can tell i'm recording from on
the road you know what that means i did
not sleep well last night i didn't sleep
well last night because i wasn't
on my magnificent helix sleep mattress
helix sleep has a quiz it takes just two
minutes to complete matches your body
type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you
why would you buy a mattress made for
somebody else with helix you're getting
a mattress that you know will be perfect
for the way you sleep
everybody's unique helix knows that so
they have several different mattress
models to choose from they've got soft
medium and firm mattresses
mattresses that are great for cooling
you down if you sleep hot even a helix
plus mattress for plus size spokes so
if you're looking for a mattress take
the quiz order the mattress you're
matched to the mattress comes right to
your doorship for free you don't ever
need to go to a mattress store again
helix is awesome you don't need to take
my word for it helix was awarded the
number one best overall mattress pick of
2020 by both gq and wired magazine just
go to helixsleep.com
take their two minute sleep quiz and you
will get that mattress matched to you
delivered directly to you they've got a
10 year warranty try it out for a
hundred nights
for you got nothing to lose it is a
fantastic mattress my wife and i have
one helix is offering up to 200 bucks
off all mattress orders and
two free pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com
go check them out right now okay so the
point here
is that if the left declares that you
are a nazi which increasingly
seems to be happening then the next move
is you can use whatever resources are at
your disposal
in order to stop the nazis from rising
and you can see
how major institutions in western
society are being weaponized
toward this so let's take a quick and
kind of amazing example
so yesterday the aba
which is an organization that is
dedicated to selling books the american
booksellers association
right which is an association of
bookstores across the country
they put out a statement the statement
they put out was about abigail
schreier's book irreversible damage now
we've talked to have gail schreier on
the show
i recommended her book it is it is an
excellent
book it is it is a it is all about the
damage done
to young people by giving them hormone
therapy and
genital surgeries on the basis of
supposed gender dysphoria without proper
diagnosis and without
any sort of longitudinal data right the
book is really well thought out it is
very sensitive book it is not a sort of
hard charging wreck everything but at
all
okay abigail's a very considered person
okay so the aba put out this statement
quote an anti-trans book was included in
our july mailing to members
it is not an anti-trans book it is a
book considering whether rapid onset
gender dysphoria is a problem
by data it very clearly is quote this is
a serious violent
incident violent that goes against abas
ends policies values and everything we
believe in support it is inexcusable
we apologize to our trans members and to
the trans community for this terrible
incident
and the pain we caused them we also
apologize to the lgbtqia plus community
at large
and to our book selling community
apologies are not enough we've begun
addressing this today
and are committed to engaging in the
critical dialogue needed to inform
concrete steps to address the harm we
caused
those steps will be shared in the next
three weeks
okay so you have an actual bookseller's
association
apologizing for the violence act of
distributing a book
and this is the mentality that has taken
over with regards to major institutions
throughout american society
you must apologize if you cross the left
you've committed an act
of violence by simply allowing for the
distribution of a book
they weren't pushing the book they
weren't saying that the book is the only
book on trans issues there are many
books pushed
by the american booksellers association
that are fully in tune
with the far left cultural zeitgeist
that suggests that boys can be girls and
girls can be boys and that you should
propagandas that that's a kiss right im
jazz is the kind of stuff that the aba
also sells and promotes and loves
okay but if there is one book they don't
like it can be banned
same thing with ryan anderson's book
when harry became sally which was banned
from amazon you literally cannot buy it
on amazon
because it is quote unquote anti-trans
okay this sort of institutional takeover
is extremely dangerous and when it
becomes clear that it is not just coming
from wokes inside particular
corporations encouraged by the media
i've talked a lot on this program about
how corporations have basically been
hijacked by their woke staffers the
bosses are too chicken bleep
to actually stand up to their staffers
and say no we're not going to do any of
that
so the media have militarized this the
far left media have decided what they
will do is they will find a couple of
employees
disgruntled employees inside a company
and they will get those employees
to talk about how offended they are by
something that the company is doing
and then the company responds by doing
what the disgruntled employees want
you have a couple of amazon employees
who will complain about abigail trier
nbc news will do a story like a full
story about two amazon employees
quitting we talked about this yesterday
two amazon employees out of 800 000
american amazon employees
quitting and then they will put pressure
on amazon to get rid of abigail
schreier's book so that is one problem
a far larger problem in terms of formal
problems
and problems that should scare the
living hell out of you our government
actively attempting to use the chief
means of distribution of information in
our society
the social media companies in order to
set
boundaries on what information you can
consume now remember
the original good of social media
companies was that it was a marketplace
of ideas it was a town square of ideas
section 230
of the communications decency act was
explicitly directed
at providing a greater forum for these
sorts of for
uh to actually grow you wanted facebook
to exist so that people could exchange
ideas
in the early days of facebook mark
zuckerberg talked very clearly about
this
by the way so did jack dorsey right the
idea over twitter the idea was that
these were going to be places for
exchange of ideas where there would be
discussions where you could access all
sorts of information you never would
have gotten if you just subscribed to
the new york times for example and
people took that seriously and they
started
consuming their news via social media so
instead of just going directly to the
new york times or to the daily wire they
started going to their news feed
on facebook and then media members
started attempting to
push and and ram facebook
in order to circumscribe what kind of
material you could access through your
newsfeed
right so you get kevin russ from the new
york times saying too many people are
visiting ben shapiro's facebook page
you need to curtail that you need to
make sure that the traffic to daily wire
goes down for example the only
sources that should be trusted are the
new york times and now
you have the federal government of the
united states that is pushing this as
well
and again the ideology here is that
there are people who know better than
you
and those people not only have better
moral standards than you they know what
constitutes
on a quote-unquote objective level
disinformation
now i have my own ideas about what this
information constitutes i for example
think it is an overt and abject lie
when joe biden says that the voter id
laws of georgia are somewhat akin to jim
crow
i have there there's not only no
evidence for it it's a lie it's just not
true
facebook ain't going to crack down on
any of that but i wouldn't expect
facebook to crack down on that nor do i
think that they should because that's
not their job
but the left believes it is their job
because here's the thing i don't think
that joe biden
is hitler but joe biden does think that
people like you
people like me apparently people like 60
70 80 of the american population that's
in favor of voter id
are like jim crow segregationist racist
and therefore
why shouldn't facebook crack down on
them so this mentality was pushed
forward yesterday by the former
prime minister of denmark and a member
of facebook's oversight board she kind
of expressed the general overlying
theory here she said here's the thing
all these platforms yes they're for
freedom of speech but this must be
balanced
with other concerns here's what she had
to say well we're trying to find
of course i think many of us were
engaging in this conversation
is that is that middle road how do you
moderate content and when
how do you find that balance between uh
human rights
and free free speech this is a human
right but also other human rights
because
already spring speech is not an absolute
human right it has to be
balanced with other human rights and
that is what the oversight is there
to do okay so again facebook has now
integrated itself with this idea that's
health learning schmidt who is again a
former prime minister of of denmark
and is promoting the idea that facebook
needs to balance freedom of speech
with other concerns well really they
shouldn't
right the reality is it's not really
facebook's job but as we'll see
governments are going to use this this
inroad as a way
to silence voices they don't
particularly like we'll get to that on a
formal level
in just one second first let's talk
about the fact that if you've got a
medical problem you really should just
go get it solved this is particularly
true if it's something that really
affects your life like erectile
dysfunction with roman you can get a
free online evaluation and
ongoing care for ed all from the comfort
and privacy of your home a us licensed
healthcare
professional will work with you to find
the best treatment plan if medication is
appropriate it ships you free with two
day shipping the whole process is
straightforward and discreet
getting started is super simple just go
to getroman.com
complete an online visit take care of
your ed without leaving your home
complete that online visit today to
connect with a healthcare professional
and get it taken care of go to
getroman.com right now you get 15 bucks
off your very first month
it is really time to take care of your
ed remember get started today you'll
save 15 bucks on your first order
of ed treatment that is getroman.com
ben g-e-t-r-o-m-a-n dot com
slash ben right now you get 15 bucks off
your first month of treatment if you
have a medical problem like erectile
dysfunction
i know it's embarrassing to talk about i
know something you wish would just go
away the reality is not gonna go away
until you get it taken care of go to
getroman.com
get a consultation complete an online
visit and then get the medication you
need getroman.com get 15 bucks off your
very first month
if once again you can label all of your
political opponents extremist
unworthy of public debate then you can
militarize private institutions to stop
them
and this is exactly what the white house
basically announced they were doing
yesterday this is an unbelievable thing
it really is it should scare the hell
out of everyone right left and center
because if the trump administration had
said
we've called up facebook and we've told
them we think that they are distributing
this information
and we need them to take down that
misinformation right now for the good of
the republic
and also if they don't you know we do
have oversight power with regard to
facebook
and now democrats have been making these
sorts of signals for a while you'll
recall that dianne feinstein called the
senator from from california
called mark zuckerberg before a senate
committee and she said if you don't stop
this sort of stuff we will
which is a direct and open threat that
we are only going to give you a level of
immunity
as long as you do what we want which
does make them a quasi-state actor in
the sense that they are now
operating at the best of the government
and government cannot use state actors
or quasi-state actors private
institutions that are operating under
the under the
explicit direction of the government in
order to violate your rights
and the government does not have the
power
of for example unreasonable search and
seizure so if the government hires a
private contractor and says i want you
to break into that guy's house
and look in his house they are now a
government contractor
or if they say you know what if you
don't if unless you break into that
guy's house and sir and ransack his safe
we are probably going to prosecute you
the government would be the actor in
that particular scenario
the government is verging very closely
on that when they say things like
we are directly telling facebook what
kind of content we want to come down
that is extremely extremely dangerous
whether i agree with the kind of content
that they're attempting to take down
or not and as we'll see the reality is
that whatever the left declares
misinformation very often is not
misinformation
so yesterday the surgeon general of the
united states blamed big tech
for coveted misinformation they said oh
well you know if big tech could just
cracked down on kobe misinformation
there'd be less vaccine hesitancy okay
let's be clear about something
people who are vaccine hesitant are
vaccine hesitant for a wide variety of
reasons
one of those reasons is the public
health debacle that has been the
messaging
from the biden administration the trump
administration was no great shakes when
it came to
public health information there were a
lot of conflicting messages from
the fauci no one should wear a mask to
the pouchy everyone should wear a mask
but the body administration has not only
been no better in many ways they've been
worse
since the advent of the bible
administration anthony fauci has said
that if you get a vaccine
you still can't take off your mask he's
still suggesting right now that
three-year-olds ought to be wearing
masks around in public which is patently
crazy
okay so all of this creates vaccine
hesitancy and then when you have the
biden administration
pause j and j the j j vaccine after six
cases of some sort of rare blood
clotting disorder after seven million
doses a lot of people go wait hold up a
second you know the risk to me on covet
it ain't that great it looks like there
might be a risk to me from the vaccine
so maybe i'll wait
now i'm a huge advocate of the vaccines
i think they are mirror i think they're
miraculous in nearly every way
i see no reason why i should inject my
seven five or one year old with the
vaccine
at this point like they're not they're
not subject to serious risk from coven
and it's up to the adults to get
vaccinated kids have never been at
serious risk from covid statistically
speaking
kids are more likely to be killed by a
lightning strike in the united states
than they are to die of covid
something like 311 people under the age
of 18 total in the united states have
died during the entire coven pandemic
compared with well over 600 000
americans of other age groups who have
died
most of them in the older age range okay
but putting that aside
here is the point much of what has been
distributed about kova that has been
misinformation has been coming
directly from your government anthony
thatcher was saying overtly false things
repeatedly on a wide variety of topics
ranging from schools should stay closed
to don't wear a mask to you need to wear
a mask even after you're vaccinated
right like that that sort of stuff was
going out so
should the administration of the united
states be the
body that determines what facebook
should leave up and what facebook should
take down here's the surgeon general of
the united states blaming big tech for
not taking down
what the white house wanted them to take
down modern technology companies
have enabled misinformation to poison
our information environment
with little accountability to their
users
they've allowed people to intentionally
spread misinformation what we call
disinformation to have extraordinary
reach
they've designed product features such
as like buttons
that reward us for sharing emotionally
charged content
not accurate content and their
algorithms tend to give
us more of what we click on pulling us
deeper and deeper into a well
of misinformation first of all the idea
that confirmation bias
only exists because of facebook is nuts
confirmation bias exists when a liberal
new yorker
subscribes to the new york times it's
confirmation bias when when
biden fans watch cnn or msnbc that is
confirmation bias confirmation bias
is an inevitable fact of life okay and
people tend to seek out news that they
agree with from sources that they
already agree with
okay that's a negative it's why on my
show i've recommended many times
they listen to this show and then you
listen to shows that disagree with me
and you see who you like better and who
you think is telling you the truth more
i've noticed that many shows disagree
with me do not provide the same sort
of notification of their own bias but
having the surgeon general of the united
states blame facebook
for covered misinformation and for
vaccine hesitancy is crazy
it's the exact same tactic that the that
the democratic party took in the
aftermath of 2016 when they suggested
the real reason hillary clinton lost was
because of facebook
it was not because hillary clinton was a
crappy candidate it's because of
misinformation and disinformation on
facebook the reason they said this is
because they want to bring
facebook under their control they wish
to bring big tech under their control
they wish to use these as instruments of
the democratic party and if they can do
so informally
then they can effectively end around the
first amendment of the united states by
weaponizing institutions
as governmental agents that's what they
are attempting to do here jen sachi made
this absolutely clear yesterday
i mean this is wild authoritarian
garbage here's jen saki saying
you know what we've been doing we've
been actually notifying facebook what we
think is is disinformation and telling
them to take it down
that is you really want the white house
doing that you want the white house
going
to like if the white house came to the
new york times and said we need you to
take down that story it's disinformation
do you think the new york times would do
it obviously not
if the biden white house came to us here
at daily wire and they said you know
that story that you have up
we think it's disinformation take it
down we might evaluate whether it is in
fact disinformation but we would then
use our own independent judgment and
taking it down we wouldn't take the
white house's word for it
the white house is attempting and the
white house doesn't have power over us
the white house has a lot more power
over for example facebook than it does
over our
our news website but here is jen saki
pretty much openly admitting that the
power of the white house is now being
used to leverage private companies
into subverting free dissemination of
information
we've increased disinformation research
and tracking within the surgeon
general's office
we're flagging problematic posts for
facebook
that spreads this information we're
working with doctors and medical
professionals to connect
uh two connected medical experts with
popular with popular who are popular
with their audiences with
uh with accurate information and boost
trusted content
i mean this is insane they're basically
saying we want to run
these social media platforms from the
white house
from the white house and if you don't
let us well then i mean
i'm not sure we can hold back the
anti-trust regulators guys i'm not sure
we can
and barack obama did some of the same
stuff with regard to corporate america
and the immediate aftermath
of the of the economic crash of
2007-2008 and he famously said to a
bunch of banking ceos
i'm the only thing that stands between
the mob and you and
they're they're out there holding
pitchforks you need to do what i want
you know using the power of the
government to force private industries
to do what you want them to do makes
them quasi state actors and removes
the defense that these are private
actors who can do what they want because
they obviously can no longer do what
they want
it makes that defense very very tenuous
hey the hhs released a full statement
yesterday on what technology platforms
can do strengthen the monitoring of
misinformation quote platforms should
increase staffing of multilingual
content moderation teams
and improve the effectiveness of machine
learning algorithms in languages other
than english
since non-english language
misinformation continues to proliferate
platforms should also address
misinformation in live streams which are
more difficult to moderate due to their
temporary nature and use of audio
and video prioritize early detection of
misinformation super spreaders and
repeat offenders and impose clear
consequences for accounts that
repeatedly
violate platform policies and who
determines who determines what is
misinformation the white house
this white house trump's like who's
white house who determines what's
misinformation
the fact-checking apparatus that is
solely run at this point by members of
the left
factcheck.org which is always willing to
grant a
half-true rating to anything a democrat
says but
a four pinocchio wholly untrue statement
to openly true things
that people on the right say and
in the in the area of information there
has to be open discourse
otherwise the truth doesn't come out if
it it'd been up to the
biden white house let's say let's say
biden president last year
okay and the biden white house would
have been pushing very hard presumably
for facebook to take down quote-unquote
misinformation about the covet lab
league
theory okay that that in fact they
didn't even need to
many of these technology platforms were
banning people
and censoring people for doing just that
for speculating that
the covet virus started in a lab league
well now it turns out according to the
washington post
that the who said it will fix several
unintended errors in a joint report with
china on the origins of the culvert
crisis and will look into other possible
discrepancies in response to questions
from the washington post the who is
changing the virus sequence ids
associated with three of the 13 early
patients listed in the chart in the
report
and we'll clarify the first family
cluster was
not linked to the juanan seafood market
in wuhan a spokesman said so the entire
narrative that this thing started wet
market in wuhan was
nonsense from the beginning the wbho
covered it up and now the who is
uncovering it up but
if the informational dissemination had
been completely cut down last year you'd
never find out about this
of course the danger of people
controlling these streams of information
is extraordinary remember for years we
were treated
to the idea that the steele dossier
might in fact be fact
and now it turns out of course that the
steele dossier was sheer patent nonsense
that was come up with
by a a kind of discredited spy on behalf
of the hillary clinton campaign
laundered through fusion gps but for for
years that was reported
on these platforms as true so you're
going to trust these platforms to
determine what's true and what's not
true
and more importantly you're going to
trust government actors to tell these
platforms
what is true and what is not true
there's an entire article in new york
magazine today
by t.a frank titled the steele dossier
was a case study
in how reporters get manipulated to pick
the worst press failure of the past half
decade would be a daunting assignment
but the coverage of the steele dossier
would have to be high on any list
the document penned by former british
intelligence agent christopher steele
was commissioned in 2016 by the private
research firm fusion gps
in turn working for the presidential
campaign of hillary clinton the aim was
to dig up dirt on donald trump
especially regarding any ties he might
have had to russia
steel delivered alleging a long-standing
conspiracy between trump and the kremlin
and offering details that proved to be
as unfounded
as they were spectacular although they
were almost certainly species these
claims spawned countless news stories
including
at new york magazine and prompted
government investigations into possible
ties between moscow
and trump the steele dossier is just one
recent instance of the media presenting
the public with information that
originated in a vast and opaque industry
of private spies and operatives for hire
who do business without all the rules
and ethics of traditional media outlets
but who often inject their version of
events into the mainstream press by
feeding tips and scoops to reporters
and this is what happened with the
steele dossier for example now we are
finding out by the way
that when the tech platforms shut down
all the talk about hunter biden
we're now finding out according to
politico
that last summer in the middle of the
summer federal officials in delaware
already had enough information to seek
search warrants and issue grand jury
subpoenas
in the hundred biden criminal
investigation last summer
if the new york time if the new york
post mentioned that a month before the
election they were kicked off the tech
platforms
okay this is extremely dangerous stuff
and again
it is it is ends justify the means kind
of thinking
donald trump had to go this justified
not only overt misinformation like the
seal dossier
and and the russian ramp up and all of
that it justified bans on the new york
post a month before the election cycle
and it justifies the white house now
telling these tech platforms what they
can leave on
and what they have to take off if you
don't think that that is
authoritarianism i don't know what to
tell you that is authoritarianism
it is authoritarian it is state-run in
the same way that the chinese government
props up full corporations and then
steps in and de-lists them from the new
york stock exchange when it sees fit to
do so
if private companies in the united
states are subjected to the regulatory
oversight of the people who are telling
them
what to do with their actual content
moderation now this is a state-sponsored
enterprise
and now you have to start wondering who
is actually running the show is this
free and fair competition
is this free and open dissemination
information or is this a backdoor
violation of the first amendment
in the name of strike bear democracy and
stopping the nazis who live next door
we'll get some more of this in just one
second because it all comes with a
friendly face of course we'll get some
more of this in just one second first
let's talk about the fact you don't want
to go to the auto parts store because
who wants to go to the auto parts store
instead you should head on over to
rockauto.com it's so much easier than
walking into a store waiting in line
forever finally getting to the front of
the line
answering very specific questions about
your vehicle and then finally the person
behind the counter is like hey you know
what we don't have that in stock i'm
going to order it and up charge you
instead head on over to rockauto.com
they always offer the lowest prices
possible
rather than changing prices based on
what the market will bear like airlines
do
why would you spend up to twice as much
for the same parts their family business
serving auto parts customers online
for 20 years go to rockauto.com to shop
for auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers the catalog is unique
it's remarkably easy to navigate you can
quickly see all the parts available for
your vehicle and choose the brands
specifications
and prices you prefer head on over to
rockladder.com right now see all the
parts available for your car or truck
right shapiro
in there how did you hear about usbox so
they know that we sent you again that is
rockauto.com
get the best prices best inventory
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available and write shapiro in there how
did you hear about usbox
so they know that we sent you
alrighty we'll get to more on all of
this in just
one second first it is that glorious
time of the week when i give a shout out
to a daily wire member today
it's andrea jessup on twitter who
understands the importance of quality
craftsmanship in the pic the majestic
left this year's tumblr is resting
comfortably
on the back of a pickup truck that has
just arrived on a job site as the sun
begins to rise the caption reads
my husband just sent me this the world's
greatest beverage vessel held on his
entire way to work also my coffee tastes
amazing when i use this tumbler hashtag
leftist tears tumblr
you see folks there is no substitute for
the best this happy couple knows it
thanks for the pick
thanks for being a daily wire member
meanwhile as you may have noticed
the institutions of our society as i've
been discussing have been weaponized
against you
they're being weaponized against normal
everyday americans and it's every
institution
from facebook and twitter to the
scientific
authorities who are now masking up again
in l.a like all of these institutions
have been corrupted re-normalized and
weaponized against you
my book the authoritarian moment is
about how this happened and more
importantly you have to understand how
it happened
so we can now reverse it it's available
for pre-order right now the book again
is the authoritarian moment it helps you
understand
how we got here why it feels like you
are under assault and how we
re-normalize
make normal again those institutions
that have been taken over
and weaponized i'll be doing a live
signing of my book in the coming weeks
so if you want to pre-order your signed
copy and ask me some questions
that you might be lucky enough for me to
answer during my live stream you need to
head on over to premierecollectables.com
moment if you pre-order a copy don't
forget to type whatever your burning
question may be into the prompt or when
you check out and seriously
unless you would like to live under the
authoritarianism that seems to be rising
in the country it's time to start
reading up and fighting back also
if there's one person in america who is
not afraid to speak reminded as candace
owens now she has an entire show
where she does just that here at the
daily wire it's called candace
every episode features her fearless
brand of political commentary and
in-depth interviews with interesting
guests her latest episode
cuba communism and the democratic death
cults is available right now
on demand for daily wire members if you
haven't subscribed yet get 25
off a new membership with code candace
at dailywire.com
subscribe you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show
in the nation
[Music]
now the wonderful thing for the
democrats and for joe biden is that if
their political opponents are so
unthinkably terrible if they are just
the worst people
in the world you never ever have to work
with them and increasingly this is the
perspective of the biden administration
so yesterday the democrats in a rather
little noticed
change they just got rid of the hyde
amendment so the hyde amendment is a
long-standing bipartisan agreement
between democrats and republicans that
there will be no direct federal funding
of abortions
that if there is money that goes from
the federal government to for example
planned parenthood
it has to go into their non-abortion
activities now it's a bit of a legal
fiction
in the sense that all money is fungible
so if you fund planned parenthood's
rents they take the money they were
going to use for their rent and then use
that for abortions but
at the very least the federal government
was not going to be
directly involved in the funding of
abortion and this was agreed to
for decades literally decades going all
the way back to henry hyde proposing it
decades ago
you know his big supporter of this joe
biden well yesterday house democrats on
monday
took steps to advance a new spending
bill for the dhs without
dhhs without the hyde amendment in
moving the spending bill to the full
house appropriations committee for a
debate and vote
democrats followed through on president
joe biden's proposed budget which also
did not include
the amendment house democrats had
indicated they would go this route and
in doing so have effectively guaranteed
that abortion access will be a central
focus of government funding negotiations
between
democrats and republicans who do have
the votes to block the democrats measure
from passing the senate without changes
the full house panel is expected to
approve the bill and send the measure to
the chamber for a vote it's not yet
clear if the measure can clear
the narrowly divided chamber without the
hyde amendment given democrats slim
majority you'll remember that in 2018
joe biden was in favor of the height
amendment and then he reversed his
stance
because of course he was running to the
left in order to try to fend off
bernie sanders the idea was that the
federal government abortion was so
threatened by the states the federal
government had to step in
and they had to fund abortion and now
they're going to ram through your
taxpayer dollars
funding other people's abortions at the
federal level
on a sheer party-line vote because the
people who are standing in the way of
that are so bad you definitely cannot
work with them
so they're getting rid of the hyde
amendment totally right you see the
house appropriations committee chair
rosa deloro
of connecticut saying allowing the hyde
amendment to remain on the books is a
disservice
to our constituents alexis mcgill
johnson president and ceo of planned
parenthood federation of america said in
a statement her
organization was thrilled quote for far
too long the racist and sexist tight
amendment has put the government in
control of a personal health decision
for many people with low incomes
has it though because all it says is
that i'm not paying for your abortion it
doesn't bad abortion in any way it's
i will not pay for your abortion nor
should the taxpayer
but the broader point here is pretty
simple democrats have basically decided
they no longer wish to work with people
on the other side of the aisle
and their excuse for not attempting to
negotiate for not attempting to be
bipartisan is those people are just so
bad we can't even talk to them
right this is why shinsaki is now saying
that you know joe biden has changed his
mind he would love to have amnesty
in this gigantic 3.5 trillion budget
bill
he would love that sounds great to him
now you may be saying to yourself wait a
second it's a budget bill what is that
like shouldn't there be a separate
immigration bill that's negotiated
especially because in the past there
have been these sort of gang of eight
scenarios gang of 12 scenarios where
republicans and democrats have put
together a framework
for what to do for example about the
so-called dreamers people who were
brought to the united states as children
and their parents were illegal
immigrants and they were children so
they were not born in the united states
what to do about those folks there has
been some attempted bipartisanship on
this in the past
now democrats are like those republicans
are just so terrible we won't negotiate
with them we're just going to ram this
thing through here's jen saki saying
yeah you know after all
old joe here he would love amnesty in
the budget bill
say that they want to put a citizenship
pathway into the reconciliation package
is the white house supportive of that
strategy yep
yes yes yes and not only that chuck
schumer has now signaled
that he is going to force a vote on the
quote-unquote bipartisan infrastructure
plan negotiated
by mitt romney on the one side and
people like kristen cinema
on the other there's a 1.2 trillion
dollar infrastructure plan schumer's
plan here
is force the republicans to vote on the
bipartisan plan
before they get to this 3.5 trillion
plan they plan to shove down at the same
time
which they're going to want to share
party line vote now mitt romney
needs to say i will not vote for this
unless i have assurances from joe
manchin and kristen cinema that they do
not vote for the boondoggle plan
basically this whole silly game was
created by the democrats in order
think of a think of a water balloon if
you squeeze one end of the water balloon
all the water just goes to the other
side of the water balloon this is
basically what they've done
with their two-part strategy their
two-part legislative strategy
right on what they've said is we've
here's the bipartisan bill bipartisan
bill was two trillion dollars
and here was the sheer party line vote
bill and let's say that that bill was
going to be three trillion dollars well
if we squeezed out like a trillion bucks
here in the bipartisan bill it'll just
inflate
the partisan bill over here and it'll
get larger and so in the end the
combined bills will be the exact same
amount of spending
it's just that joe biden will have been
able to say that he did it with the
veneer of bipartisanship this needs to
stop now
romney needs to make clear that it's
going to stop now unless mansion and
cinema
kill the 3.5 trillion dollar boondoggle
that biden is pushing forward
but again this is not about productive
conversation for the democrats it's
about hard-nosed
politics your political opponents are
evil and you will ram
everything that you can through on a
sheer party-line vote
and by the way radically change the way
that the government is done
in the united states without necessarily
killing the filibuster now the the
democrats are really
pretty openly it happened for a while
calling for the end of the filibuster
because after all the republicans are
just so terrible they're just such jim
crow segregationists that we can't have
the filibuster anymore that needs to
completely
go away well what does this result in
what this results in
is more and more americans feeling like
you know what
i don't have a ton of commonality
with people in the rest of the country
if the federal government
sees me as the enemy if the
institution's weaponized
by the federal government or in
coordination with the federal government
in coordination with the media
if those institutions are weaponized
against me if i'm the guy
that is going to be called by the joint
chiefs of staff nazi because i voted for
trump
if that's who i am well then i don't
wish to share a country with you there's
a new poll out
showing support for essentially regional
unions
and it's pretty fascinating poll this
poll is courtesy
of yougov okay and what the poll shows
is that 66
of republicans in the southeast ranging
from texas
to to florida say that they would be
interested
in seceding from the united states to
join a new regional union
now this is sort of paralleled by the
northwest in the northwest
47 percent like basically the west coast
47 percent
of democrats say that they would like to
secede from the united states to join
a new regional union in other words
where people
are living in more red states or more
blue states they feel more alienated but
particularly people in red states right
now feel
like they are under assault which is why
they are seeking more
state level action more strong governors
in order to stand up against federal
predation this is just going to continue
it's just going to continue
and all the unity that joe biden
promised it doesn't exist so long as joe
biden refuses to say to his own base
that your neighbors are not the enemy
and he refuses to
if he doesn't refuse to characterize his
neighbors as the enemy
this is going to get much worse much
much more quickly alrighty we'll be back
here later today with an additional hour
of content first
you can't forget to end your week by
checking out the andrew clavin show
drew's shows every friday he's got an
exciting evening planned for you as
always head on over to dailywire.com
at 7 pm eastern 6 pm central tune in i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavel wydowsky
associate producer bradford carrington
host producer justin barber the show is
edited by adam sciavitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina production
assistant jessica crans
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching
and the moons turn to blood but on the
andrew clavin show that's where the fun
just gets started so come on over to the
andrew clavin show and laugh your way
through the fall of the republic with me
andrew clavin